scat the new flu runner man it's got the
the next one that claims my video good
back remember the rules there are three
of them
you laugh you loose okay but I did three
life remember the rules it's very
important also hit the bell button
subscribe let's freakin do this is what
is called bone to hollow Mesa you give a
poor man a fish and you feed him for a
day you teach him to have two fish you
give him you give him fine I don't care
what is happening as the update says you
give a poor man a fish and you feed him
for a day you teach him to have you
teeth moving oh I still got two guys
it's okay I can't freaking do this you
only get one life so don't even curry is
the capital on Glee sludge is that
really what it says
can anyone from Russia please translate
just know it's England the capital of
England is England everyone knows that
[Music]
no no I did not like it was not funny
moving on he thought Ebola booty well so
does this country roads
it is Sami sisa Aussie country roads I'm
just confused
to be honest very Kauai destiny I'll
take it
another Skyrim me I don't think so
you'll have been taken by the quality is
so good I really understand everything
Thank You Skyrim very cool oh look at
that
I got a Skyrim bonus heart looks like
I'm fine excellent
I don't understand I just don't
understand
is this what tick tock is is this the
the core of tick tock have we finally
reached the bottom is I don't think he
gets better than this this is a plus
content leave what you heard me now
please don't do this are you sure you
want to do this little girl I mean what
if what if we're dangerous wait is that
we're walking dead what in my room what
I forgot complete that can't be real is
that real that what if I am what if I am
Oh what if I bit my time I bit my tongue
okay are you happy I like the shirt get
it together Felix you got to show your
bros how it's done no more laughing from
this so non-normal Ahmed never liked who
bigger
bigger bigger Jeff bigger yeah
it's bigger yeah bigger
[Music]
bigger
yeah
[Applause]
no this clip is called oblivion
walkthrough part 3 my life ma'am ma'am I
came in here to find out something about
the surgery my doctor wants to do on my
heart well I know you're upset and
you're scared about this angioplasty
procedure but we just don't seem to have
anything on clogged arteries and balloon
surgeries I'm sorry you know I may not
make it through next week and also I
have breast cancer what is the room oh
that jerk Harold he wants me to give him
a share of my house that house belongs
to me
he has no right I am not giving him a
penny who does he think he is he's your
brother
he is always bugging me about my house
15 years ago we agreed that house
belongs to me now the value of the house
is going up and he's seen dollar signs
everything goes wrong at once nobody
wants to help me and I'm dying you're
not dying I got the results of the tests
back I definitely have breast cancer and
I guarantee you as a mother of two boys
that I would do everything illegal legal
it doesn't matter what it is to get my
children into this country is there a
problem with that yes yes you would let
somebody rape their child oh she didn't
say anything she did say anything okay
but maybe you didn't have to go there
right away I'm just saying what would
you do if there was a child right in
front of you hey kids
good good old chuckle do you sometimes
wish that April was a turtle did you
want to say something oh look at the
child on the left there it is that's
epic
[Music]
how dare you show that clip I'm not
cheating Dawson if I see your stupid
face again mr. duck okay keen how do you
deal with all this drama and not so
crazy yourself
that's so funny I actually feel better
now
good me good job duck me did I lose yet
I don't think so how many are money life
sir I have left I'm cool it looks like
I'm winning
epic did paper monsters come out before
Paper Mario I did it
hold on want to find out that paper
monster there make it up let's see if
pay Paul wing didn't rip it off wait
when did it come out lawrence when the
paper mario come out look that up make
sure make sure paper monsters is not a
ripoff mm came out mm so paper monsters
recut you still don't know when it came
out you should be you should be a lawyer
for this company company whole length
lair Oh
bruger to eat fruits emerge me Oh how do
we know which red ripped off what the
judge wiki's it was like came up we
didn't tape monsters recut and is that
let's Wikipedia anybody can edit that
you see free report came out in 2013
does it 64 games came around 2013 I
don't think so sir you betcha with me
wrong prove me wrong walk over to Paul
Wayne don't worry Renison we're good
we'll get out of this don't worry Paul
turtle with spikes
nobody's ever put a turtle of spikes in
division please
wait there's Turtles those spikes in
Super Mario Brothers what up ok that was
epic
that was a good laugh lunch you had one
last well I think it's time to in that
episode there does anyone have a new
display I'm looking to buy a new display
I didn't mean to hit it with a hard car
it was just a meme God